Film Courage: Sometimes the film just finds its place.
So that was a statement I heard you say in
an interview and I think also just a second
ago. Did [Orson's movie] The Queen of Hollywood Boulevard
find the place you thought it would or
did people actually find something new
about it that was fascinating to you
that you're like "Oh okay wow,
it didn't find the place I thought it
would but they like this about it?" Orson Oblowitz, Filmmaker/Photographer: Yeah I
mean I think I mean I think you kind of
have to go into every film shooting for
the stars you know everyone wants me in
Sundance everyone wants me in SXSW
everyone wants to be in kin and Venice
and there's a million reasons why you
might not get in there but you don't get
it and then you got to see what where
does it where can it live you know and I
found that through a series of curators
and programmers like Boston underground
Film Festival and Beyond fest
and a bunch of place mammoth in these
places or sure the first places to
accept it it start finding this really
cool audience of real cinema lovers you
know of you know I didn't really see it
when I made it as even though it was
based off all these 70s call films I
loved I didn't see it as like a jean or
a cult movie and that's where it started
living and it started finding this
really cool audience of people and yeah
I mean it's it's so it's funny as so
many things were run through my head
when you say that like what to find it's
I think it's still finding its place I
think it's in its release online now and
it's unshut er it's on all these you
know shutter which I love and it's on
Amazon it's on to be all these different
outlets for it I think it's starting to
find a cool core group of followers that
really like it you know and I'd really I
think it's really cool that you know
maybe some films have a million people
that like it means one film has 100
people like it but they love it and it
means a lot to me that they love it and
I get Amit like I got a few emails
recently just out of the blue or
Facebook messages from people and they
were like this film just like hit me
like I don't know what it is and I've
never met these people
my life I never had anyone reach out to
me so it's kind of a surreal surreal
experience even on a small level because
the film did it become a giant success
right it did it become come a breakout
hit you may have I don't know if I ever
thought that's what it was gonna be but
debt you know the opposite of what what
a the yep not the opposite um say
succinctly I think it's still finding
its ah its core audience and the film is
of the film's audience is evolving all
the time and I think that's when human a
film finds its place and it finds its
life there they're almost like living
organisms movie they they go they work
their way through a nervous system of
content and media of Technology now and
I think audience members are very smart
at this moment and they have a lot of
options and I'm very grateful that any
audience member chooses to see my watch
my film when they have tens of thousands
of other ones and the fact that it has
started finding a core audience and
finding an audience of people that have
even reached out to me about the movie
is really special and yeah it does go
the film a film finds its place you
can't force it I like that and I think
you also have talked about you want to
make movies that create dialogue so is
it that you're okay if somebody doesn't
like it as long as it's creating some
interesting conversation because not
everything even we put out people get
upset over the smallest thing but I'm
actually satisfied when it's creating a
conversation yeah I had a college
professor they used to say that making
art was to incite discourse and I truly
think that's all that kind of matters in
the end of the day you know good or bad
that's your Chinese dinner you know was
the food good was the food bad films are
much more complicated that than that
even films that don't seem to seem to be
that way all art is all art is asking
you to just go dig a little deeper so
nothing
any happier than watch then hearing or
seeing people talk about my film I don't
care if you hate it the worst thing I
could do is be media is I could do and I
think any filmmaker or artists to do is
be mediocre
and we die in mediocrity and I think
right now in this crazy Content Laden
world that we're in I think our biggest
enemy as artists is mediocrity and
that's my goal as a filmmaker I don't
necessarily think I make great movies I
don't some people hate them and I'm okay
with that because I just want if you're
gonna talk about it if it's gonna bring
up conversation if it's something that
in any way and sites you to discuss
anything I'm happy and that's just how I
feel you know did you see the
documentary on Chris Burden he was the
artist artistry shot I've never seen him
but I know is I his art you did the LACMA Lights yeah and he got shot in the arm
and he made the train set over there
well I think part that was part of his
art thing was to do the shooting yeah
when he got yeah yeah the film I'm
shooting it getting in the arms
right yeah I love that see how I love
performance artists and and I love that
type of art and I don't think I'm that
shocking in any way I'm not like Gaspar
Noe or someone like that but even
though those are my I love those
filmmakers John Waters and Gasper Noe
real transgressive cinema you know that
pushed us Harmony Korine but I think
yeah I were just like Chris burden it's
just like that you know recently at the
Venice Biennale this artist whose name I
can't remember he brought to this Venice
Biennale and put it in a museum in an
art gallery a boat that migrants died on
Oh on their way to Greece I believe and
he put it in the in the gallery and a
lot of people were like you know that's
exploitative that's whatever I go well
you're gonna talk about it so you can
say whatever you want about about the
artist but he did his job his job was
done now now it's your responsibility as
critics as audience to go discuss it and
you figure it out so yeah well in a day
and age when people are getting arrested
for helping people in the desert and
giving them water you know that are
trying to
whatever your feelings are they're still
there and they're Thor whatever and and
now people are being surveilled Oh
helping people so that's an interesting
statement
yeah totally it's a giant statement that
he's making and I believe we are living
in a very polarizing time of like on one
hand you do have like a shame like the
surveillance state and the and
third-world living is going into the
worst it's ever been the discrepancy
between rich and poor is terrible and
there's all these and these are all
things that without knowing if people
are analyzing them film you know in a
horror movie that is about clowns
killing homeless people it might
actually be it it might actually have
some subtext to this idea of politics so
that's like my point about film I just
think we deserve to the filmmakers to
just look a little further into what
they're doing sometimes I know Chris
burden you faced a lot of backlash not
just from non just not from not just
from patrons but from the art world and
I think he you know he became quite
upset and isolated himself a little bit
but it also drove him further into his
work so you know that's that's the thing
do you become so I don't know if oven
guards the right word but successful at
creating this conversation but then it
creates that that's the part I hate to
see an artist that it chunk them it
makes them shun the world you know well
I think people forget how sensitive
artists are you know and I'm not
apologizing for artists because as an
artist you get to live the greatest life
you know the blessed life you know you
get to create and that's a beautiful
thing and I think but there's a certain
yang to that and artists are very
sensitive and they take their work very
serious I think a lot and now in the day
of Twitter and and social media
everyone's a critic right and even more
than that with Chris Burden and where
people really ostracized him but at the
same time that became his legacy he
became a legend because of that you know
so who knows what the you know in in the
end it's it's a it Konig he goes back to
idea of like a film finds its place like
art finds its place as well and whether
that's good or bad people as well it's
kind of hard to judge you know look at
great I mean it's gonna get dark for
singing but look how many great artists
have themselves right people who
you thought we're on top of the world
and they've you know because we don't we
never know about someone's inner
monologue so that again it just goes
back with art and with film and with
media and I think one of the things eyes
a filmmaker hope to do just a little bit
it's just a SAN audience to be like just
talk about it just discuss it just just
spend know that like these stories are
for you and we love that you enjoy them
and we love for you to discuss them
you